- PRE-SCHOOL FIELD TRIP,
AND NOT A SINGLE FATALITY?
OH, HOW REFRESHING.
JUST DOING MY JOB.
HEAD RANGER ETHEL,
OVER AND OUT.
[sighs]
GOOD JOB, ETHEL.
OH, THANK YOU, ETHEL.
- CONNIE, I NEED YOUR HELP.
WOODY'S GIRLFRIEND
IS BAT-SHIT CRAZY.
- SHE SEEMED NICE TO ME.
MAYBE YOU'RE JUST JEALOUS.
- YEAH,
AND MAYBE YOU'RE JUST--
UGH, I DON'T EVEN HAVE
THE ENERGY TO INSULT YOU.
JUST STEP ON A SCALE.
- HEY!
WHERE'S ALL THE DANISH?
IT'S BEAR CLAW WEDNESDAY!
- NOW IT'S FRESH FRUIT
WEDNESDAY.
- [spits] UGH!
THIS DOESN'T TASTE
ANYTHING LIKE A DONUT!
I HATE IT!
[grunts]
- HEY, I DIDN'T GET
TO EAT YET!
UH, BUT IT'S OKAY.
MY MOTTO IS
"EFFICIENCY THROUGH POSITIVITY."
BY WORKING TOGETHER,
WE CAN ACHIEVE GREATNESS.
[phone ringing]
SORRY,
PROBABLY REALLY IMPORTANT.
BRICKLEBERRY NATIONAL PARK.
HEAD RANGER ETHEL SPEAKING.
THE PARK EXPENSE REPORTS
ARE LATE?
WE HAVE THOSE?
I'LL GET RIGHT ON THAT.
[beep]
SORRY, CAN YOU HOLD?
HELLO,
HEAD RANGER ETH--
WHAT DO YOU MEAN
THE LAKE'S ON FIRE?
[phone ringing]
OH, MY GOD, HOLD ON.
- ETHEL, I CAN'T COME
TO WORK TODAY, I'M SICK.
- DENZEL, I NEED YOU HERE.
HEY, ARE YOU ON YOUR JET PACK?
[phone ringing]
- NO.
- HEY, LOOK,
IT'S A FLYING BLACK GUY!
- MAYBE.
[phones ringing]
- CALM DOWN.
A BADGER ATE YOUR BABY'S FACE?
[beeping and ringing]
HOLD ON.
MY EMERGENCY SCANNER'S
GOING OFF!
THIS IS ETHEL!
WHAT'S YOUR EMERGENCY?
- ETHEL, IT'S STEVE.
DID YOU KNOW THAT CONNIE
IS AFRAID OF RAW FISH?
- WHAT?
- [screaming]